the escalation caucus that's the focus
of tonight's angle
all right i want to clue you in on
something earlier today the ingram angle
fielded an inquiry that was both
perplexing and revealing from our dear
friends at newsweek
apparently this intrepid reporter some
fellow named gerard kayonga who's based
in the uk
was stunned that the angle had the nerve
to raise questions about the wisdom of
sending these soviet-era migs from
poland to ukraine
laura warned of it causing deaths and
not just the russians what did she mean
by this mr kayonga asked
well what part of this is confusing
obviously escalating the conflict
doesn't just mean more russian troops
would die
it means more ukrainian civilians could
die as well
now if putin is clearly the megalomaniac
that many have made him out to be and he
very well may be then
who knows how he'd respond to america
engineering that mig transfer
but of course the unknowns are part of
every war which is why every step
must be carefully gamed out
now mr kayonga's questions though didn't
stop there laura also opposed the claims
made by tom cotton and mitt romney on
the importance of doing this
what does she believe could happen and
how could things escalate
well as far as opposing tom cotton and
mitt romney big deal first of all we
love tom cotton but does newsweek
only approve of certain republicans
opposing other republicans after all
the press corps has a hot and steamy
love affair going on with liz cheney and
adam kinziger
so
are so-called reporters
really this lost
putin's entire justification for this
inhumane and cruel invasion has been
concern about nato encroachment toward
russia
and thus it would seem logical that
sending migs from a nato member country
into ukraine could give him a sea i told
you so a moment
so why is it unreasonable to posit this
real possibility
answer
it's not
in fact it's the responsible thing to do
the question we shoot right back to
newsweek is a simple one
why aren't people who call themselves
real reporters asking the uncomfortable
questions
didn't they learn anything from the last
time they threw in with the warhawk
consensus
i should know i was one of those people
who reflexively joined the wage war at
any cost bandwagon you know after 9 11.
anyone else feel like this is all just
kind of a back to the future moment at
this point why do you feel that the west
is not completely embracing that and
saying this is the war and we need to
get into it even with this additional
aid that you're providing today it seems
there are still other options on the
table so why hold back
and the department of war over at nbc
even press gensake yesterday
there's a growing chorus of voices
saying that now is the time
has the president reconsidered his
stance at all at this point they have
several squashed squadrons of mission
capable aircraft i don't think that's
enough john you've heard presidents that
are not being christian that are not
christian that are not being utilized
this is the assessment by our defense
department
now if i were zolinski i'd probably be
appealing to americans by invoking 911
and pearl harbor as well
anything to get more weapons and buy
more time i get it
putin's assault on civilians is pure
evil we all see it
so zielinski's calling for a no-fly zone
totally understandable
but when american politicians try to use
this
uh this thing of sending migs to ukraine
as some kind of litmus test for
patriotism
we find it repugnant
as is anyone trying to pretend
that none of this poses a massive and
potential risk to america
you're telling me logistics that's
what's standing between innocent babies
and mothers in ukraine we can't give
jets to pilots who are able to fly them
we can do it i feel fully committed to
doing everything in our power to help
defend the people of ukraine against the
monstrous actions of vladimir putin and
that means getting the people of ukraine
the migs that they would need to fight
and shoot down some of the russian
aircraft history will judge us
if we don't act now and if we don't act
strongly
military strategists who specialize in
battlefield tactics game out every move
and every step of the way they ask
serious questions questions like
will migs actually help turn the tide in
ukraine
and can ukraine even maintain these
older fighter planes
or is the media's position that it's
better to consider these issues after
we've spent billions replacing poland's
migs
now this spend now ask later approach is
how the u.s ended up without a victory
in iraq
and in an embarrassing defeat in
afghanistan we spent trillions
we lost thousands of our brave troops we
lost contractors and hundreds of
thousands of iraqi civilians to fight a
war that created an exodus of iraqi
christians and also the rise of isis
saddam was gone a great thing but much
of iraq was as well
a total nightmare
this is precisely the time now is the
time for vigorous and open debate
and one voice that should be heard is
that of u.s navy reserve officer blake
herzinger who writes in foreign policy
that most of ukraine's fighter aircraft
are still in the fight flying
approximately 5 to 10 missions per day
using a pool of about 50 jets
russian aircraft are flying nearly 200
missions per day but keeping their
planes primarily within russian airspace
both sides are likely exercising extreme
caution to avoid ground-based air
defense systems given this knowledge a
score of soviet-era air superiority
assets would not meaningfully improve
ukraine's military situation and there's
more
poland's migs are decades old and many
were hand-me-downs when the polls
receive them
fighters especially older ones require
considerable maintenance as well as an
insured pipeline of spare parts and
munitions
ukraine's capability to sustain those
extra aircraft
is unclear
so asking how soviet-era migs will hold
up against newer russian jets with
advanced avionics and defensive
capabilities
is an entirely rational question
so why is the establishment so afraid to
answer it
why are they afraid even to allow the
question to be asked at all
but
there is at least one democrat who dared
to raise a legitimate point washington
congressman and chair of the house armed
services committee adam smith flatly
stated
the mig wouldn't last a second in
ukrainian airspace right now
look maybe he's right maybe he's not
but the american people must be told
that the risks of escalating things with
russia are not negligible
it may in fact draw us even closer to a
direct confrontation with russia which
as we all know is a nuclear power
so is this what americans really want
if not
isn't it incumbent upon their elected
representatives to stop and do a
meaningful risk benefit analysis
and as for the laptop warriors at
newsweek
perhaps they wouldn't be writing for a
digital only publication if their
writers had the ability or the desire
to step back from the unfolding tragedy
as horrific as it is and identify all
the parties who are prolonging a war
where there are no winners
oh and i almost forgot
mr cayongo only reached out to us for
comment
less than 20 minutes before he published
his silly little piece about us
at 7 am
such as journalism in 2022
fifth grade antics fourth grade
intellect and that's the angle hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else